in this video we'll be talking about
neuroinflammation which refers to
inflammation that occurs in the central
nervous system which includes brain and
the spinal cord so this inflammation
Could Happen due to brain injury or even
infection so let us take some examples
so one of the key uh disease where
neuroinflammation happens is the
meningitis so our brain is protected by
a layer known as meninges and this is
how a normal meninges look like in a
normal individual but this is how
inflamed and infected meninges look like
so meninges can be infected by bacteria
leading to bacterial meningitis like
streptococus neria or uh leria as well
there could be viral meningitis Kaki
virus hepatite harpes virus HIV virus
can infect the meninges there could be
fungal as well as parasitic meningitis
as well so all these things lead to a
inflammation of the meninges which might
have overall effect on the brain
functionality now the question is which
type of cells take part in the
neuroinflammation so how does
neuroinflammation hampers the overall
brain
function so our brain contains different
type of cells apart from the neurons
including gal cells like asites
oligodendrocytes and microglia all of
these G cells talk to each other
and they also talk to the neurons and
thereby creating a gal and neuronal
interface so these gal cells are heavily
affected in
neuroinflammation and scientists thinks
that many of these gal cells including
microglia and astrocytes are actually
the driver for
neuroinflammation so key Focus has to be
given on microa and
asites so microa has diverse set of
roles not every role is associated with
neuroinflammation but diverse roles
include eliminating damaged neurons
synaptic
pruning release of reactive oxygen
species release of inflammatory cyto
kindes recruiting olgod dendrite
progenitor cells promote neuronal repair
and even fyto siiz debris of foreign
materials or let's say a pathogen when
it invades the brain so
thereby it's really important in context
of overall brain function microglia
always survey the cellular
environment if you look at the resting
microa one can see the processes are
approaching and retracting several times
as if they are surveilling so they are
looking for some uh Invaders so the
surveillance mechanism is pretty
prevalent in terms of microglia so
microglia are dynamic they are like
security guards always monitoring for
local environmental changes is microa
can also work like scavengers they
engulf cellular debris they engulf
damaged portion of the neurons as well
so microa has specific receptors known
as pattern recognition receptors or
damage ass which recognize damage
Associated molecular pattern or pathogen
Associated molecular pattern and thereby
it can engulf these damaged Dees or even
entire pathogen and preventing them to
harm the
brain now one of the key function of
micro GLA is basically synaptic pruning
so the way microa affects the brain is
altering the synapsis thereby it has the
potential to alter the brain function
micral activation due to brain injury
and infection is an important aspect so
whenever there is an injury in the brain
microglia converts itself from a resting
state to a activated microglial State
activated microglia secret several cyto
mines which are pro-inflammatory in
nature which attracts many other cells
including tea cells so how does
microglia know which is the injury site
it turns out the injury site secretes
ATP which is recognized by the
purinergic receptor present on the
microglia and thereby they can reach the
sight of injury and evoke
inflammation sometimes this
neuroinflammation is for the good for
the brain but sometimes The Chronic
level or beyond control level of
inflammation is bad for the brain and
that's what happens in many disease now
microa are diverse there are different
types of microa each of these microglia
has their own molecular marker and own
function so there are specific microa
which are discovered which are heavily
associated with diseases they are known
as activated microglia or disease
Associated microglia one such evidence
comes from Alzheimer's disease many of
the Alzheimer risk genes are actually
enriched in microglia such as strem 2 or
msa4 so so that is why people think that
microglia could be also a driver for
neurod degenerative disorders anyway
this hypothesis is still
debatable anyway in Alzheimer's disease
the microa engulfes many of these plucks
and they becomes reactive they secrete
cyto mines like incin 1 6 tnf Alpha all
which are pro-inflammatory in nature
they interact with asroy with these cyto
and make the asites reactive as asites
further can affect the neuron and
synaptic properties thereby it creates a
vicious cycle in the Alzheimer's
brain now in Alzheimer's brain people
have identified a specific subcategory
of microglia known as disease Associated
microglia but how these microglia are
generated and how they are different it
turns out they downregulate micral
checkpoint genes and they have
upregulated phagocytotic and lipid
metabolism Gene still scientists are
trying to figure out how they are
beneficial or detrimental for the
Alzheimer's brain now when it comes to
neuro inflammation and disease multiple
sclerosis is one of the disease which is
heavily associated with
neuroinflammation so it leads to in this
disease there is a progressive
destruction of the mine Sheed around the
axon which leads to plethora of
symptoms and that gets worsened over
time so there are several cells like
oligodendrocytes which are helping in
the myelination process in the brain and
endite has unique proteins known as
milin basic protein Pro lipid protein
and myin
oligodendrocyte all of these are pretty
native to olroy so they are not supposed
to be recognized as foreign but due to a
immune Mal malfunction in multiple
sclerosis these proteins are detected or
recognized as foreign entities and
thereby autoreactive te- cells are
generated which further activates B
cells which differentiates into plasma
cells which secretes antibody against
these
oligodendrocyte and thereby damaging the
entire myeline Sheed and this is the key
cause that evokes inflammation in these
um in in the brain and the spinal cord
of multiple sclerosis patient it is also
found that not only these autoreactive
te- cells harm the brain in this way but
also they differentiate into other
subtype such as th1 and th17 th17 is one
of the uh t- cell that produces incine
17 which is a pro-inflammatory cyto and
people are still debating whether these
are the key cell types that can evoke
inflammation in context of multiple
sclerosis anyway there are cells that
can suppress autoreactive T cells known
as T regulatory cells and in case of
multiple sclerosis there is a
disregulation of these T regulatory
cells which cannot prevent the excessive
activation of autoreactive te- cells
that ultimately leads to to inflammation
not only multiple sclerosis in context
of Parkinson
disease the neuroinflammation is pretty
predominant it has been seen micral um
activation and micral morphology
alteration in the autopsy of the um
Parkinson disease
patients now when it comes to amyotropic
lateral sclerosis neuroinflammation is
involved because reactive astrocytes and
microglia are found in the nervous
system of ALS patients so when we took
the example of these disease throughout
these disease we can understand that
there are reactive astrocytes and
microglia which can lead to
neuroinflammation that brings us to an
idea that not only cells cellular States
can be a important driver of disease
progression maybe astrocytes and
microglia are good in their ground state
and they they are required for the brain
activity but when they are forced or
push push to become reactive then they
then they become harmful like you are
normally cool or chilled in your normal
state but when somebody agitates you you
become agitated and you become Furious
so this is a nice analogy that can tell
you not only cleal cells are important
in context of um neuroinflammation the
reactive states and their specific
subsets are really important in that
context also neuroinflammation is
associated with entis
which is associated with viral infection
but micral activation is Hallmark in
this particular disease as well so we
understood and appreciate the common
theme that is micral activation as a
driver for neuroinflammation so I hope
this video was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
see you in the next
video